hey good morning to all of you Harvey's
unrelenting rain continues now for a
fourth day and officials say the worst
flooding is yet to come
Houston is already paralyzed some areas
could get another foot of rain by
tomorrow morning I don't know where that
water is gonna go this storm has broken
an all-time record for the biggest
rainfall from a tropical system that was
set all the way back in 1978 when Texas
got 48 inches of rain from tropical
storm amelia we've got the rescue
efforts they are still going full force
police the Coast Guard volunteers are
all saving people trapped in their homes
by rising water
but those evacuee spaced more hardship
the convention center behind me is
packed in fact CBS News has learned that
more than 9,000 people spent the night
there last night that is nearly double
its official capacity last night there
were just people lined up trying to get
in so they're not turning anybody away
they're letting them in but they are
maxing out capacity at this facility
governor Greg Abbott is calling Harvey
one of the largest disasters America has
ever faced the White House says FEMA's
three billion dollar disaster fund will
be enough for the immediate response but
FEMA is saying it needs more money soon
and Congress will have to appropriate
President Trump is heading to Texas this
morning to check on relief efforts
during a joint news conference with
Finland's president yesterday he
promised help to those impacted by
Harvey recovery will be a long and
difficult road and the federal
government stands ready willing and able
to support that effort Jamie yuccas is
at Corpus Christi International Airport
where President Trump will be flying in
Jamie good morning
good morning the president first lady
will land here shortly before noon
they'll then be briefed by officials on
the recovery efforts happening happening
here now while he has declared a state
of emergency for parts of Texas this
will be the first time he gets an
up-close look at Harveys damage in
coastal communities across Central Texas
the recovery has just started Aransas
Pass suffered heavy damage when Harvey
made landfall this strong storm changed
the landscape it even took down the
city's water tower this 71 year old
woman rode out the storm in her mobile
home which is now resting on its side no
that's not I was going to happen just
across the bridge Port Aransas is
ransacked
there is no power no water to drink or
food in this city on Mustang island some
folks lost everything there's a water
line right here you can see it's about
four and a half foot up the wall
President Trump promised Texans they
would receive federal funding for
rebuilding efforts Texas governor Greg
Abbott says the work will be a years
long process that's something you can't
just snap your fingers and make happen
we're all going to be in this together
it's going to take a long time doing it
governor Abbott activated all 12,000
members of the Texas National Guard
these members of the Texas guard handed
out water and other supplies Monday in
rockport a small town of just 10,000
people which took a direct hit the
debris is seemingly endless
volunteers drove in yesterday to lend
their support and offer a helping hand
if it was 30 miles west it would have
been us there in Corpus so these are our
friends families neighbors the President
and First Lady will spend about two
hours here in Corpus Christi
they will then head to Austin's
Emergency Operations Center will they
they will be briefed by Governor Abbott
before heading back to Washington the
president says Nora that he could come
back to Texas on Saturday all right
Jamie thank you so much